russell impaglia who's a professor at
ucsd and needs no introduction and the
talk title is connections between
pseudo-administer machine learning
thank you
um
so
um i'm hoping you know so the previous
talk mentioned zero knowledge and uh i'm
hoping to uh live up to that standard of
conveying no knowledge
uh beyond uh the pro beyond the um
the statement that i want to convey is
that uh really
we should always be thinking about
connections between different areas and
in particular
the two areas pseudorandomness and
machine learning even though they're
they're uh usually have like disjoint
communities they're really a flip side
of the same uh intellectual endeavor and
we should be like approaching them
together even if you're even if you're
not trying to do one or the other you're
good you know even if you're not you're
doing one and you're trying not to do
the other you're gonna accidentally do
the other
so they're really uh the same
so i was trying to do pseudorandomness
okay and i kind of explain uh
why
i realized i was doing machine learning
uh when that was not my intention okay
so
these two areas are like thought of as
having like very different motivations
pseudorandomness comes from cryptography
from de-randomization of algorithms
machine learning comes from more applied
areas where you're trying to actually
understand data of the world and so on
why are these kind of intellectually the
same
so let me just
prove that in a picture
in a series of pictures i hope and then
we'll and then i'll spend the rest of my
talk giving some anecdotes that are fun
for me
okay
so
what is pseudorandomness about
pseudorandomness is about data that
maybe has subtle patterns but where
those patterns are
not observable to an outsider
they're hard to discover
okay
machine learning is about discovering
the patterns the subtle patterns and
data
okay
so um
and uh
yeah
that that is
okay i don't actually i don't know if
the red lines are visible if you like
trace the red lines you see that this
was actually a fish
array
okay
um
so uh so this means
well so i just convinced you that
they're diametrically opposed right that
um that machine learning skulls are
exactly the opposite goals of of
pseudorandomness that's true but that's
why we need to study them together
because you can't study one thing
without studying its opposite
okay so
this is why
uh machine learning and pseudorandomness
are kind of
uh
they're they're
directly opposed to each other in some
way which means that their study you
know we as like
uh
intellectual observers supposed to be
objective
to understand one the issues in one are
going to
be the issues for the other it's the
same kind of
background issues about when you can do
transform one thing to another thing and
of course
we're not actually just objective
bystanders we're actually like when
we're proving a theorem we're really
rooting for our sign
right we want our machine learning
algorithms to work
we want our data to be pseudorandom
and we want it to be
not
the patterns to be hidden from these
machine learners okay so
what happens when you to get a
connection between
machine learning and pseudorandomness
often there's a psychological barrier
you have to start rooting for the other
team
so once you start rooting for the other
team you find that you're doing the
other one
okay
so let me give an example uh of where uh
so i'm just gonna go through and see
where this kind of connection through
opposition
came up in my own work
without my realizing it for the for the
most part
so um
so uh so i'm just going to trace through
the many times that machine learning and
pseudorandom generators pseudorandomness
in some form
met in my work and i'm sure there are
lots of other people who could give
completely disjoint sets where it came
up in their own work
but then i'm especially going to say how
the simons institute enabled a lot of
these
these kind of connections to be made
okay but um but actually when i started
thinking about it i was going to like
say well let's highlight the connections
made at the simons institute but a lot
of those connections went back many many
years and i realized that like one of
the first connections dates back to
1990 kind of one of these oppositional
connections
so what was happening around 1990
especially from my perspective as a
graduate student and then a
recent alumnus
from from use from uc berkeley um
a lot of the excitement was about
realizing
that the foundations of cryptography you
know that that we could have a very
unified foundation for cryptography
okay namely if one-way functions existed
there were lots of things uh that we
could do with them okay a lot of
cryptography was possible based just on
a one-way function and that included
pseudorandom generators pseudorandom
function generators secure signatures
secure bit commitment
zero knowledge and a lot of other uh
desirable things uh
can't would come from just having a
one-way function
okay so
seemed like
having a one-way function would be great
but what if we didn't have them
uh oh
what if these things don't exist
so
is there any like bright side
to one way functions don't existing is
that are there any algorithmic
consequences for one-way functions
non-existing
and i guess kind of like uh
my motivation for wanting some
algorithmic consequences is i still
wanted to believe that one way functions
existed
so
if there would be algorithmic
consequences that would be too good to
be true that's actually a reason to
believe one-way functions actually exist
if there would be unbelievable
algorithmic consequences
so uh a result along these lines
actually came was in a joint paper
myself and leonard levin in 1990
it actually
was kind of tagged on by leonid to a
paper on a completely different subject
so i'm not even going to name the paper
so he came up with a great out a great
result
that if there are no one-way functions
then you can do
average case learning in a very strong
way
okay
the only problem
uh
and he was going to make me an author on
this result so i was very excited but
the only problem is that
leonid
either doesn't believe that machines can
learn
or maybe he believes that machines could
learn but we shouldn't encourage it
i'm not sure
but he totally refused to use the words
machine learning in the paper anywhere
so we had to write a
a paper or i had to kind of like
translate what we initially written
because
you know how leonard writes papers
it
it's like the three-page paper
that is like three phd thesis to
interpret okay so
and takes like a decade so um
so uh
uh so i had to like
hint at what this the significance of
his result was without saying it
um and i think i totally failed
so i think no one actually
even people in the area don't know about
this result
fortunately they do know about uh
related work by uh avram blum uh merrick
first uh mike kearns and dick clipton uh
just a little later that really kind of
explains the connections between one-way
functions and and machine learning
a lot better
in a lot more accessible terms by for
example using the term machine learning
okay
so um
okay
so and there's in this actually uh
you can
this is
i say like
not a lot of people know this result
to tell the truth i don't really know
this result
in the following sense
that um
again when i'm trying to i've like
taught this in different classes over
the years and every time i teach it
i not only
give a different proof but i give a
different statement of what the result
is
because i want to like explain
what kind of learning is possible and
you can
you know you can like say oh yeah pack
learning is possible on uh distributions
that are samplable that's true but it
doesn't really explain the complete
significance of the results it's a lot
stronger than that and actually
very recent work by
moni naor and yogev
showed even further generalization
again in a paper
that doesn't mention
one way functions or
machine learning in its title
uh
it's actually called something like uh
something about bloom filters
and so you really wouldn't know to look
for it in that paper so
but it's actually a pretty nice result
that even extends our work
and shows this very strong learning as
possible if there are no one-way
functions
okay so here we have the opposition if
one-way functions exist pseudorandom
generators exist very strong
pseudorandom generators if one-way
functions don't exist machine learning
and in the techniques that we use to get
those two results are are pretty much
identical
so uh
so i ran into this kind of connection a
few years later
when i was trying to like avoid
doing the same kinds of
presentations that i that i always did
so i was trying to like move out of my
comfort zone because i had been teaching
this grad uh you know topics course and
i always pick topics that i was very
comfortable with based on my own work or
people you know that i already knew
about and i said
that's not the way to teach a topics
course you shouldn't teach things you
already know about you should learn new
things and teach them
so i said i'm going to learn
something completely different something
i know nothing about and i'm going to
try to teach that
and stretch myself
and so uh my friends at cmu were really
excited about jeff jackson's uh phd
thesis in machine learning learning pac
learning of dns
so i'm going to learn this paper and
present it to my class
really stretch myself learn a completely
different area that i know nothing about
and then uh i started uh
reading the paper
and it had three
main like
you know i'm not trying to so it's a
really good paper but it had three main
like techniques that they use
that he used the first one was fourier
analysis i said okay well i guess i
don't have to start from you know i had
just presented fourier analysis
in the class lineal means or nissan okay
well that'll be familiar to my students
good at least we have like some it won't
be a complete leap for them okay then
how about the second chapter
the second chapter was about an
algorithm by kushulevis and mensur for
finding large fourier coefficients and
when i thought about it this was this
goldrich glove theorem from cryptography
okay and i'd already taught it
okay so oh well uh
uh there must be something in this paper
in this thesis that i haven't already
taught in the class and there was
the last chapter was about boosting
last ingredient was boosting and i
hadn't taught it before i had just used
in my most recent paper
on pseudorandomness without knowing what
i was doing
so the the paper was called the hardcore
distribution lemma and it turned out
that what i was doing in that paper was
boosting
so i'm going to make a digression and
actually tell you what the hardcore
distribution limit is and what boosting
is and why they're the same
so what i was trying to do
is
go from a somewhat hard problem to a
really hard problem and uh a lot of
times the intuit we said like the
intuitive reason why say you have a
problem that no algorithm can get the
answer right 95 more than 95 of the time
and it's a boolean problem
yes no
so the like we always like started by
saying well intuitively what should be
the case is that 10 of the time the
problem looks like a coin flip
and 90 percent of the time it's easy and
that's why you can't do better than 95
of course you can't you know that's the
intuition but you have to
to to do the argument you have to do
something completely different
as far as a formal argument and then i
thought maybe you don't
maybe that's what's really going on all
the time
and so i came up with this hardcore
distribution dilemma that actually
showed that if you're hard 95 of the
time there's this 10 percent
actually i proved five percent and then
later holdenstein proved 10
uh
part of the space where the the function
is essentially pseudorandom
looks like a random bit
uh
okay
and uh i had one there were actually two
proofs in this paper
one uh that i came up with and then
that seemed somewhat constructive
of course it's you know
we're talking about complexity so how
constructive it's going to be uh
but it seems like it went in stages and
you and you started constructing a
circuit
uh and so it seemed
i liked that aspect
but then gnome nassan came up with a
completely non-constructive proof just
invoking the min max there
so i was really happy when i realized
that what i was doing
was uh uh
in when was actually an algorithm and it
was actually a useful type of algorithm
a boosting algorithm
so um
okay
so what is uh a boosting algorithm okay
so uh
it actually has like there are many
uses of the word boosting in machine
learning now but it started as a way of
making a
a pack learner so pack lerner gets black
box out you know gets black box samples
of a function a boolean function and is
trying to
output
from those samples a function that
agrees with the labels uh say like 99 of
the time
and uh
well a much weaker goal
is let's just get an algorithm that
agrees with the stamp outputs a
hypothesis that agrees with the labels
51 of the time
okay well there's a huge gap between 51
and 99
and what a boosting algorithm does is
com it converts uh weak learners to
strong learners
it takes the 51 percent learner and
combines different runs of this 51
percent learner on different weightings
of the inputs until it gets a 99 where
99
hypothesis
okay and this has been a a really useful
idea both in the theory of machine
learning but also in uh applications of
machine learning
and
for example uh this is uh i think them
the people who introduced uh boosting
shapiro freund and shapirae and um maybe
my currents getting uh the kucha levitz
not the kuchi 11 uh the
kanalakis prize
kuchi levitz will come up there but
in a minute but that's not who i'm
talking about now yeah that's not who
the prize is named after
okay
so um
okay so
so and
by trying to just understand this uh
this idea from complexity theory i had
accidentally rediscovered boosting and
the great thing is that um
uh
i had discovered
for the it actually was a kind of useful
new twist on boosting that i had come up
with
called uh that um cliven sir video and
then cliven sensor video called smooth
boosting
and the reason why this was a useful
twist is that in general boosting
algorithms even the most successful ones
they have this kind of arbitrary
re-weighting of the inputs
and under this re-weighting process
sometimes one of the inputs just becomes
more important than everything else
combined
okay and if that one was mislabeled and
that was you know one reason why it
becomes more important is that you keep
on getting it wrong and you get fun
getting it wrong because the answer was
wrong that you were given is wrong
so
then it just becomes uh really more
important and you the noise has just
overwhelmed the rest of the
the the algorithm
the rest of the data okay in smooth
boosting we have a control over how much
we can reweight data so that maybe you
can
you know double or triple the original
probability but not more than that
okay
and um or if you're going for 99
accuracy you can multiply it by a
hundred
so for boosting algorithms uh this
prevents it's actually used turned out
to be useful for preventing overfitting
to
or using somewhat noisy data
and uh for our purposes this kind of
bounded re-weighting actually guarantees
that the
that the hardcore set we find is 10
uh
not just a vanishingly small fraction
so uh so
uh but if you have any of these smooth
boosting algorithms you can use it to
prove a
a dense
uh hardcore distribution lemma
uh
just by again what i said you root for
the other team
so in the boosting algorithm we have
this weak learner
we're running it we're relating the data
running the weak learner again
reweighting the data and you know what
we hope is that this weak learner keeps
on succeeding
and so we eventually find a a
a
hypothesis that outputs the function 99
of the time
in the proof of the hardcore
distribution lemma we do exactly the
same process
except we're hoping for the weak corner
to fail
so we know that the strong learner will
not succeed
because there is nothing that computes
the function 99 of the time
so we're waiting
for that weak learner to fail and when
that weak learner fails we pounce and
that's our hardcore
so again it's
it's just changing the success condition
so that failure equals success
um that makes a difference
uh
so
this hardcore uh distribution lemma
turned out to actually be uh
well i didn't you know later
there was like an even more kind of
intricate web
between uh topics in pseudorandomness
and topics and you know different goals
in machine learning
and uh
and
pseudorandomness from complexity
pseudonymous from uh a graph theoretic
point of view pseudorandimus in number
theory even
and uh the person who kind of re helped
reveal this connection to me was luca
trevison
in 2007 when i was at the institute for
advanced study
so he gave a
so there had been like this really
recent breakthrough
in number theory
by tao green and siegler
that showed that the the
set of primes had arbitrarily long
arithmetic progressions
and at one point in this argument they
start talking about pseudorandomness of
the prime numbers or a pseudo-random
distribution where the prime numbers is
big in this pseudo-random distribution
so so that kind of like uh
peaked the curiosity of some people like
luca
in complexity theory
uh how is this pseudorandomness idea
being used in pure or in
uh
in number theory
whether mathematicians consider that
pure math or not i don't know
okay so uh so he looked at this art he
reingold uh tulsiani and vedan
looked at this argument from um
from the number theorists and kind of
like codified it
and translated it into um
into complexity terms
and i should mention uh
that uh when they did the translation it
turned out that there was like related
work already being done in the
complexity by barack sheltiel and
wigterson
um
so
uh
again like
exactly
you know here i'm trying to give
uh a historical talk in like
every historical talk in mathematics
that i'm aware of
things
when you actually look at the history
there's like the story you want to tell
and then there's the actual history and
in actual history things happened in the
wrong order
you know the story makes a lot more
sense than what actually happened
so uh
okay
so
uh
so what is this what was going on in
this you know what was the fundamental
issue in this mathematics and uh
in this number theory
uh work and uh
so
it's actually like a uh
a really kind of important
uh
methodology or uh
or approach to lots of that applies to
lots of different areas in mathematics
computer science and so on uh called the
randomness structure
kind of trade-off
okay so
a lot of objects
they have a lot of kind of apparent
structure when you look at them at a
high level
but when you look at the details the
details kind of look random
uh
you know
so uh
so you want like to say you know to
explain the object
you want to say here's a high level
structure and then just fill in the
details at random
it won't be the same but it'll be a kind
of model mathematical model of what's
going on
and um
there are lots of different contexts
that we can apply this to
uh
you can like look at be looking at
geometric distributions points on the
square you can be looking in the
complexity theoretic
point of view where you're looking at
the the uniform distribution and subsets
of from the uniform distribution and you
want to like
look at
models with respect to tests that are
efficiently computable okay you can look
at what the number theorists did they
were looking at the distributions on the
integers and the class of tests
turned out to be the one the
the functions of gower norms
okay
or
it also makes sense from in a graph
theory in graph theory to look at the
test being cuts
in the uh and looking at the subsets of
vertices in a graph and looking at how
you know what fraction of edges get cut
so i guess the distribution is on edges
in a graph
and um
and you're looking at tests that are
that are cuts in the graph
[Music]
and what um
what the general principle says
and i said there's lots of like
different variants
uh from the different
different communities that came up with
this idea uh
saying like you've got some subset of
your universe and you want a good model
for it and one of two things happens
okay
either
you find a
if you're you're set well think of it as
a small set
spar set
either you find a really narrow region
definable by your tests that contain a
lot of your spar set
and so you show that the set is small
or you find this very big model
somewhere else in the gra you know
somewhere else in the universe doesn't
have a prohibited a lot to do with your
small set but as far as the tests are
concerned it looks like your small set
so either your set can be proved to be
small
or it looks like it's big
and they use this in the case of the
primes they like show that the primes
are too small to to use some techniques
of zem already that show that large sets
dense sets have large arithmetic
progressions but they look like they're
large
as far as the the tests are concerned
that determine arithmetic progressions
oh
my word okay
so uh i'm not over only over the
advertised time but i'm over
already over the extra time
and
this was the
they're giving a prasada a time warning
that's much too late
okay
anyway
so uh
the point is that
i will try to give virginia the podium
in
as little time as i can manage it
the point is that
this turned out this whole thing turned
out to be equivalent to the hardcore
uh distribution lemma which meant we
could get an algorithmic version uh
that was based on boosting okay and when
you do it it turns out to be a lot like
the the idea from machine learning of
generative adversarial networks
okay
and then uh
i
uh
in 2017
there were the machine learning and
pseudorandomness
workshops programs at the same time and
so i got to have a lot of interaction
trying to like sell this program uh to
some of the machine learning people and
i think it worked out great so
there were other times when i made such
a connection and
and one of those times tony will talk
about tomorrow
so
so while
i hope i convince you that pseudoenemis
and machine learning are kind of like uh
evil twins of each other which one's the
evil one i don't won't say
and so that means that we should study
them together and the way to study them
together is to bring diverse teams of
researchers to the same place have them
communicate and that's what the simons
institute does and that's what i hope it
will continue to do for a long time
one quick question
thank you uh so aligned with your uh
presentation you hit very well all the
papers so is there any chance to
have the references somewhere
so
oh oh well
i will send a complete list of the
papers i mentioned in the talk once i
write them
because some of them don't actually
exist yet
and they have been in the process of
coming into fruition for a number of
years as you can tell
um
so so i have just like a comment another
not a question so the shapiri boosting
you know i mean i remember from mit he
was sort of falling taking a crypto
class
on uh where this whole idea of
amplifying hardness
was
front and center so it's not surprising
i mean not
okay to the level that you're saying in
terms of really matching parameters and
constructions but yeah
good point okay so
maybe i should just say it was
surprising to me but but people who've
been thinking about it before
maybe would be less surprised
well okay so maybe you could
tell me about that
okay thank you russell for the
insightful call